I I didn't think you ever wanted to get
married when was the day you realized
she really loves me not Billy the rock
star but but but
she loves me
I think I think the day my son was born
I saw it you know I mean I or I felt it
I understood that this was different
it's hard to quantify quickly but
now I've tested that many times and I've
I've questioned it many times and and uh
you know to her credit like when she
just wouldn't give up on the idea of
being married I made her admit all the
reasons she wanted to get married one of
which was also Financial Security but
that made me trust her because I was
like at least you're putting your cards
on the table right because I would have
women be like no I don't care about who
you are and I don't care about all that
it's like total
and look anybody who's worth their salt
should want to be in a successful
relationship and security should be part
of that and you've been together 10
years and you have two children together
and what happened you finally proposed
did you get down on one knee and say
Chloe
I've been a fool I I love it okay it was
her 30th birthday and I gave her a
picture of a ring that I had designed
and she immediately of course changed
the design but that was her that was our
engagement she's still mad I didn't
propose I just kind of gave her a
picture of the ring and even that day I
was going back and forth in my mind like
yes no yes no yes no but I finally made
the decision like look you've lived your
whole life a certain way and it hasn't
worked
let's try something you've been with
this person for 10 years right do
something new try try to try to lean
into success as opposed to waiting for
failure right you have two kids your
kids are great your home is stable
um it's a beautiful person a talented
person
do for them what you wish somebody would
do for you stop waiting for somebody to
do for you what you wish they do for you
why don't you do for somebody what you
think is right and I finally was able to
work all that out in my head